this is usually a place of worship but
now this church in Croydon is also being
used as a place for people to keep warm
offering friendship food and free
heating to those in need it is
absolutely essential for the community
for people who are struggling for people
who don't have the resources and just
want somebody to give them hope
encouragement warmth food and help them
to back out and face the rest of the
week thousands of warm banks have been
set up by councils Charities and
Community groups across the country
this one at Maxwell Park only opened
last week concerned that many won't cope
with Rising energy bills alongside
plummeting temperatures people that
having to make hard decisions really
about whether they can in fact turn
their heating on at home whether they
have got enough food to feed themselves
or their children
people are having to make really
difficult choices and now we're having
this really cold snap as well it's only
emphasized it and as the cold snap takes
grip across the UK cities up and down
the country face similar issues
Charities are working to help families
meet their very basic needs but even
their help only goes so far children who
go up in low-income households more
likely to do badly at school more likely
to struggle in the jobs Market when they
become adults themselves more likely to
experience long-term health conditions
so poverty living on a low income not
having the heating on doesn't just have
consequences in the here and now it has
long-term consequences for people
millions of people on the lowest incomes
will get a 25 pound cold weather payment
to help them get through winter but
Charities warn that this can only be a
short-term fix and doesn't go far enough
to address the poverty likely to impact
generations to come Shimon Freeman
Powell Sky News